the left goes corporate that's the focus
of tonight's angle
environmental
social
governance
well the acronym esg is a classification
and rating system that globalists are
now using to pressure american companies
into adopting progressive practices at
every level of their operations
and like so many really bad ideas it of
course originated at the united nations
now for years they've aggressively
marketed the concept as good for
companies good for you and good for the
planet
esg propaganda even comes in the form of
really creepy videos
asset managers who embrace the
principles for responsible investment
undertake to incorporate esg issues into
all investment analysis and
decision-making processes
be active owners and incorporate esg
issues into their ownership policies and
practices
doesn't it sound great kids well
basically think of those behind the esg
movement as the self-appointed thought
and governance police for corporate
america
so companies not on the s p 500 esg
index
are punished by institutional investors
and asset managers who themselves are
pressured to drop offending companies
from their mutual funds or their
pensions
now one of the biggest promoters of esg
is a guy named larry fink the ceo of
blackrock
blackrock is the world's largest asset
manager and this means one company has
an enormous amount of leverage to force
other companies to go woke if they want
to have the highest performing
stock in their industry i think what i'm
requesting them is
is what i see from what where our
clients money's going so if they don't
choose to do this
i think you're going to start seeing
some of these companies having lower
performing companies if you're going to
have a high performing
stock over a long period of time
you need to be doing this and blackrock
is doing it on b doing this for
ourselves on behalf of our shareholders
we're doing this this on behalf of our
employees and our clients how benevolent
what a humanitarian
larry fink will help the world fight
against pollution and climate change
human rights abuses and mean bosses
uh except
in the place where all of that is
rampant
china
blackrock is heavily invested there
which means it operates with the
permission of its communist party
now larry might want to check out the
new trove of documents detailing the
horrifying abuses against uighur muslims
at chinese detention camps going back to
2018
but i guess that's not going to stop the
blackrock china bond fund or any of
their other chinese ventures
blackrock is heavily heavily entrenched
there and their investments are only
going to get bigger
as usual with these self-appointed
guardians of climate hypocrisy and
double standards are always bubbling
right below the surface
and ditto for their political allies and
government who of course they love this
esg stuff
but what everyone needs to know
is that esg scores
are based on a set of totally arbitrary
arbitrary standards
and they actually could end up
kneecapping great american companies
almost overnight
now not surprisingly elon musk saw right
through the esg scam pretty much from
the beginning
and now that tesla was just booted from
the esg index while exxon stayed on
musk's really on the war path
exxon is rated top 10 best in the world
for environment social and governance
by s p 500 while tesla didn't make the
list esg is a scam it's been weaponized
by phony social justice warriors he
tweeted
of course he's right
and the exclusion has only worsened
tesla's stock drop which has tumbled
approximately 28 percent
in just the past six weeks alone
so brushing aside the political
motivation here margaret dorne who's s p
dow jones is head of esg indices
she tries to justify tesla's score by
citing claims of racial discrimination
and poor working conditions made against
its fremont california factory and its
response to vehicles autopilot crashes
well
the more amorphous and ambiguous esg
standards are
the more room to act your political
enemies right and reward your friends
even esg proponents like dustin lance
senior advisor at esg global advisors
concedes that clear metrics are a real
problem here he cites several factors
including a confusing lexicon of
categories and taxonomies and acronyms
which have evolved over several years
but lance thinks that es genius needs
better marketing wait a marketing
problem that's like saying biden's
economy is caused by a marketing problem
no it's just bad policies
so given the blowback that we saw
against disney for its esg inspired
moves against florida parents and then
you know musk's complaints and his reach
i think the esg crowd they know that
we're on to them and their defense is
pathetic
dustin lance tweeted esg is rapidly
becoming politicized and it's now
heavily exposed to disinformation risks
incorporating esg factors into business
and investment decisions is not about
political views it's about driving
long-term value for shareholders and
stakeholders i'll give you a translation
here
capitalism made america too rich it's
time to change that and esg can help
level the playing field got it
now musk himself is too powerful to
silence but they're going to try
other powerful interests will rise up to
protect the woke agenda of esg by urging
social media censorship of their
detractors of course
and that's taking a page from the covid
police's playbook after all and look
they're going to cite overriding health
and safety concerns i don't put anything
past these people
by the way this is all the rage at davos
of course
we are finding ourselves in a place
where we're we have increasing
polarization everywhere and everything
feels binary when it doesn't need to be
so i think we're going to have to think
about a recalibration of a whole range
of human rights that are playing out
online you know from freedom of speech
to the freedom to
you know to be free from online violence
of course this is music to china's ears
because the elites have finally come
around to the value of suppressing
speech
of intimidation tactics implicit threats
we'll shut you down and the use of broad
generalities and also a fantasy of a
carbon neutral world
for the syst the world to reach um
the world to reach
this
zero
net
zero
carbon
world
we're going to have to invest
estimates more than 50 trillion dollars
into new technologies
i think you get it right that the entire
esg movement it's just another way to
circumnavigate around the american
voters
greening the planet it's going to make
people like larry fink and his friends
richer but it's not going to mean a
freer and more prosperous america for
the average person no way
so musk and other corporate leaders must
band together
have the courage to stand up to the woke
bullies of blackrock and call out the
global elites for the frauds that they
are
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else